california experiences rolling blackouts
again in the midst of a record heat wave
protests continue to break into violence
in major cities while democrats continue
to praise jacob blake
and president trump vows to stop the
1619 project and federal indoctrination
in critical race theory i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com
ben we're going to get to all the
breaking news in just one moment first
let's talk about the fact that this
weekend maybe you finally were ready to
get some good sleep but you didn't sleep
all that well and maybe the reason you
didn't sleep all that well over this
long labor day weekend is because your
mattress you haven't been thinking about
it it's garbage you need a better
mattress and the mattress you need
is made just for you it's personalized
and just like the latte you get down
at the local coffee shop you need
something that is made just for you
and that means that you need a helix
sleep mattress helix sleep they've got a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by gq and
wired magazine
cnn and the only true thing they've ever
said called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helixleak.com
ben take their two-minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress it'll give you
the best sleep of your life i know
because i sleep on a helix sleep
mattress
as does my beautiful doctor wife it is
personalized for us which means that we
are
incredibly incredibly comfortable which
is important since our kids try to get
us up eight times a night helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners today
get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.comhelixsleep.com go check
them out right now helix sleep dot com
slash ben for up to 200 off okay so
over the weekend here in california we
had a record heat wave
where i live it was well into the 110s
out in woodland hills was like 121
degrees those massive massive heat now
this normally would be kind of minor
news it'd be kind of minor news because
hey it's california it gets hot in the
summer who knew except for every human
being who has ever lived
in california for literally thousands of
years well that
became big news why well because it
turns out that california's government
is garbage it turns out that this state
which has the highest tax rates in
america they've got a tax
rate the top tax rate in in california
is currently 13.8 percent
yeah that under the federal rate and
that means that people who are in the
top tax bracket may be paying well over
of their income to the state and federal
government california also has
tremendous sales taxes tremendous local
taxes
the only taxes that are decent in
california and that's because of a
proposition democrats seek to overturn
proposition 13 are the property taxes
okay every other tax is extraordinarily
high here in california we're the worst
tax people in america
and we have no power because it turns
out that the electrical grid
for california not only has not been
really updated in quite a while but it
turns out that we have been steadily
moving away
from efficient forms of energy creation
and toward inefficient forms of energy
creation which led
to the pathetic tweet from the mayor of
los angeles eric garcetti quote
it's almost 3 p.m time to turn off major
appliances set the thermostat to 78
degrees or use a fan instead okay let me
just
inform you if it is 110 degrees outside
that fan it ain't gonna do you one damn
bit of good you're gonna die of heat
exhaustion turn off excess light and
unplug
any appliances you're not using we need
every californian to help conserve
energy
please do your part hashtag flexalert
so i i have a question was he not aware
was all of california not aware that it
gets hot in the summer here in
california because i've been here my
entire life and it turns out it gets hot
here
super hot during the summer and when
your power goes out it is a miserable
experience
now i've been here during a power outage
and it is just terrible
we had a transformer a few years back
blue on our street
is the middle of a heat wave and we were
literally lying on the floor
of our house because we were just trying
to get close to the hardwood floor
because it was cooler than the air i
mean it is really really really hot out
here when it gets hot and that is why ac
has been such a wonderful thing but it
turns out that if you're going to
sustain
ac for some tens of millions of people
that have 40 some million people who
live in california
you're going to need an electrical grid
that is not reliant on for example solar
energy the reason that they said you
have to start shutting down
your power at about 3 pm is because a
huge percentage of california's
electrical grid
is now reliant on so-called green energy
which as it turns out is wildly
inefficient incredibly expensive
and means that you have rolling
blackouts in the middle of a record heat
wave
the department of energy had to
authorize a federal intervention
shailene hayes heinz who is the the doe
spokeswoman said tonight
pursuant to his authorities under the
federal power act in response to an
urgent request from the state of
california
secretary brillet issued a section 202c
emergency order to preserve the
reliability
of the bulk electric power system during
this period of heat and stress on the
grid
the secretary concurs with the
california independent system operator
corporation
that a grid reliability emergency exists
which demands immediate federal
intervention
while the secretary has offered this
emergency assistance to california in
this time of crisis
he also encourages state policy makers
to evaluate why the grid is not able to
handle extreme stress which could be
alleviated with the support of greater
baseload power generation
and natural gas supply and it is that
last sentence that matters the fact is
that california has been moving steadily
toward
very inefficient forms of green energy
still the majority of power in the state
of california is provided by
older reliable carbon-based forms of
energy but
we've been dumping billions of dollars
in the state of california into this
green energy that is supposed to take
care of us
and um and it has not done so the good
news is the democrats want to extend
this kind of
malpractice across the entire nation the
wall street journal had an article on
this
weeks ago right august 23rd 2020
so two and a half weeks ago the wall
street journal had a piece titled why
california keeps having blackouts
quote when rolling blackouts dark in
parts of california this month
frank wolak an economics professor and
energy markets expert at stanford
university had a painful sense of deja
vu
wolak was among the people who helped
california chart a course out of crisis
in 2001 when a poorly conceived state
electricity deregulation law
resulted in frequent power shortages
sporadic blackouts astronomical
wholesale prices and market manipulation
as californians again experience rolling
blackouts and millions more are
threatened with losing power
a warning that continues through monday
wolak said it was clear that california
policymakers completely forgot the
lessons from the crisis in their rush
to go green a big part of the problem is
that california regulators left the
state exposed to buying large amounts of
imported electricity
on the spot market during peak periods
on days where there is extreme energy
demand so we move toward green energy
and then if we fall short then we try to
buy electricity from other states but
what happens when there's a
giant call on the system and the system
is not able to meet that demand
wolak likened this to going to the
airport on thanksgiving and expecting to
fly standby
only this time the crunch time for the
state's grid operator isn't the actual
power demand peak in late afternoon
it's when the star the sun starts to
fall in early evening
and the renewable energy the state is
increasingly dependent on begins to win
remember solar energy
when the sun goes down when it starts to
go down your solar energy begins to win
because we still don't have a great way
of storing solar energy and batteries
on many days california's grid operator
now has to find ten thousand to 15
000 megawatts of replacement powers
sometimes that is somewhere between a
quarter and a half
of all of the energy needed to keep the
lights on during a three hour period as
solar and to a lesser degree wind power
falls off so we didn't have a lot of
wind
over the last several days and solar
power again began to fall off early
evening
and so everybody was stuck in 100 degree
weather
california often relies on imported
power from other states to help fill its
void
when a historic heatwave gripped the
western u.s this month the state
struggled to find a way to replace up to
000 megawatts of disappearing renewable
energy each evening it came up short on
some days by as much as half that amount
and had to call for rolling blackouts in
the middle of august and then we just
did that again
this weekend between 2014 and 2018 the
state reduced its consumption of
electricity from natural gas-fired power
plants by 21
over that same period it increased
renewable energy consumption by 54
these were ambitious mandates that were
designed to lower global warming by the
way the impact on global warming is
absolutely negligible to
statistically speaking you could replace
the entire supply of natural gas in the
state of california with solar and the
impact on global warming
would be incredibly negligible tiny tiny
tiny over the course of the century it
would just mean
that everybody would have to turn on
those ceiling fans in the middle
of this massive massive heat wave every
time there's a heat wave
there's a guy named michael pv he served
as president of the california public
utilities commission
before he stepped down at the end of
2014. he said rigid adherence to the
green policy might have gone too far
particularly in light of state decisions
to shut down two big sources of around
the clock power the san onofre nuclear
plants in 2013
and then the last remaining nuclear
plants in the state diablo canyon after
2025 so we don't even have nuclear power
in the state so it's been a disaster for
a long time here it's just that this
became absolutely clear
for all of the united states large-scale
installed battery capacity today totals
approximately 1 000
megawatts we don't have enough batteries
one california iso estimate is the state
could need up to 15 000 megawatts of
energy storage capacity to reach its
goal of eliminating carbon emissions
from power generation by 2045.
okay so again bad policy led to these
rolling blackouts i'm
constantly amazed to watch california
politicians going out there and saying
things like well
you know that this was a historic
heatwave it was so hot you saw gavin
newsom at the dnc doing this standing
out there in the forest being like
we have wildfires because it's so hot it
turns out human policy has an awful lot
to do
with a lot of the bad things that happen
here in the state of california when you
have rolling blackouts in the middle of
120 degree weather
because you didn't foresee it might get
a little hot during the summer you
stupid jackasses
this is the predictable result this is
the predictable result shocker
so we're tax billions of dollars every
single year we run a deficit every
single year here in the state of
california
we're going to raise taxes again and uh
you can't even do the basic necessities
so this is turning into a third world
country
well done california in just a second
we'll get to the continuation
of violence in cities across the country
we've been informed that the mostly
peaceful protests remain mostly peaceful
by mostly peaceful there's a study came
out said about one in ten of these
protests turned violent
seven percent of these protests turned
violent which means like 570 different
riots and looting incidents across the
united states over the past several
months
we'll get to how the weekend went i told
you all to simmer down but that didn't
happen too much did we'll get to that in
just one second first
september it is national life insurance
awareness month you didn't know that but
now you do
and now that you're aware be a
responsible human being by making sure
that your family has
life insurance now i know that you're
thinking to yourself is it hard to get
life insurance these days i mean my god
we have giant wildfires and huge heat
waves and a pandemic and everything else
can i even get life insurance the answer
is of course you can and in fact the
rates are really really good right now
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies when
you're shopping for a policy that could
last for a decade or more the savings
really do start to add up so how does
policy genius work
well it's an insurance marketplace it's
built and backed by a team of industry
experts and here's how it works step one
you head to policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need and compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price
step two you can apply for your lowest
price step three the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork
and the red tape policy genius works for
you not the insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything
for you they even have policies that
allow eligible customers to skip
the in-person medical exam and do it
right over the phone which is why policy
genius has a five-star rating
across 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google so if you need life insurance
head on over to policygenius.com right
now to get started
i'm a responsible human being so i have
life insurance for my family you can get
life insurance too at competitive rates
you can save 1500 bucks or more a year
check out policy genius when it comes to
insurance it is important to get it
rightpolicygenius.com go check them
out right now okay so meanwhile things
continue to heat up over the weekend not
just physically but also in terms
of politics i have to acknowledge i am
amazed
amazed that the trump campaign and what
can only be called an act of political
malpractice
has not made more of the fact that the
biden harris campaign is lionizing an
alleged rapist
who resisted the police before he was
shot i mean like this is amazing to me
it truly is incredible the fact is that
the jacob blake case
in kenosha which kind of revivified a
lot of these
riots and protests and and created a new
moment
okay that is an extraordinarily poor
example of
supposed police malfeasance a really
really bad example and jacob blake is
not a hero jacob blake is an alleged
rapist
and remember there was an open warrant
for jacob blake's arrest because a woman
alleged that he had gone into her room
this is a couple of months ago that he
had gone into her room in her house
invaded her house that he had her child
was asleep next to her in the bed that
he had digitally raped her
that he then sniffed his fingers and
said smells like you've been with other
men
okay and then he had run away and now
she shows up again and then she calls
the cops all of this
precedes jacob lake resisting arrest
being tased twice apparently
and not falling down refusing to abide
police commands walking around to the
driver's side of his car
reaching into his car apparently for a
knife because the knife was found on the
driver's side floorboards and then he
was shot
and the democrats have chosen to make
this person a hero they've chosen that
this person is going to be a hero not
just the democrats the media too
have decided to make this person a hero
so benjamin crump
who is the lawyer for jacob blake
basically anytime there's a police
incident the family immediately
goes directly to benjamin crump who's
been at the forefront of nearly every
one of these particular incidents
and via his office has disseminated
really bad information initially on a
number of these incidents ranging from
michael brown to jacob blake remember i
believe it was benjamin crump's office
that originally disseminated the lie
that jacob blake was there to break up a
fight between two women and was
peacefully abiding by what the officer
said and then they shot him for no
reason
well now ben crump has put out a
statement
with his co-counsels patrick salvi ii
and blurry
lamar senator kamala harris visited with
the family of jacob blake jr who joined
by phone from his hospital bed
now he he's not just in the hospital bed
because he uh is wounded
he's also in the hospital because he's
literally changed the hospital bed
because he's under arrest right now for
alleged rape
here is the statement put out by
benjamin crump senator harris had an
inspirational and uplifting one-hour
visit with jacob blake jr and his family
today
she spoke individually with each family
member about how they were handling the
trauma
and urged them to take care of their
physical and mental health in a moving
moment
jacob jr told senator harris he was
proud of her and the senator told jacob
she was also proud of him
and how he is working through his pain
she's proud of him
so which part is she proud of jacob
blake like really i'm wondering what it
is there is to be proud of
he's an alleged rapist with an open
warrant for domestic violence for
domestic abuse
and for rape who resisted arrest before
he was shot
it seems like there are a lot of things
in life that you can be proud of someone
for i'm wondering what it is that she is
proud of
exactly about jacob blake just to just
to review
kamala harris's record and how she
perceives alleged rape
according to kamala harris brett
kavanaugh
committed a rape or at least the
suspicions were so grave that he had
committed a rape he shouldn't sit on the
supreme court based on zero evidence
other than an account that was belied by
every one of the supposed witnesses to
the event
from christine blasey ford also
kamalaris declared that joe biden
like a year ago had been credibly
accused of sexual harassment and in fact
soft forms of sexual assault right he
had touched people without their
permission
that was kamala harris now she's out
there praising
a man who allegedly raped a woman with
her child in the room
and then returned to the scene and tried
to take the keys
of the house from the woman in violation
of a restraining order
jacob jr assured her he was not going to
give up on life for the sake of his
children
senator harris also discussed the policy
changes she and vice president biden
will seek
including the justice and policing act
and implicit bias training to make
things better for all americans she
encouraged them to continue to use their
voices even through their pain
to help america make progress to end
systemic racism
uh systemic racism the the vague
mush word that means nothing when heard
by everybody in the united states
but means everything to people in the
press who understand that the systemic
racist charge means that you have to
tear down nearly every system in the
united states
kamala harris didn't just have this
statement via the uh the benjamin crump
law firm she also spoke to the press
about this she said the blake family is
just wonderful
in fact she called them incredible it's
like in the list of
in the pantheon of american families it
goes like
probably you know like the rockefeller
family the john adams john quincy adams
family and then the blake family right
where the son is an alleged rapist and
the father is a rabid anti-semite who
posts stuff about how the jews run the
world
on his facebook page that that is the
pantheon of incredible families in
america here is senator harris
praising a family where the son
is an alleged rapist and the father is a
rabbit anti-semite this is this is the
vice presidential candidate for the
democrats
i mean they're an incredible family and
what they've endured and they just
do it with such dignity and grace and
you know they're carrying the weight of
a lot of voices on their shoulders and
what was the message that you should do
just to one to express concern for their
you know well-being and of course for
their brother and their son's well-being
um and to let them know that they have
support they have support they're an
incredible family guys incredible family
now
let's be clear about this the democrats
have taken the side of people who are
who are when you say credibly accused
who are very very credibly accused of
having committed sexual assault
and their anti-semite family members
those are the people they support the
cops however should go to jail
again you can watch the tape of the
incident that is a justified shooting
by all available evidence that is a
justified shooting unless new evidence
emerges that is a justified shooting
kamala harris has called for the
officers in that case to be charged
she's chosen her side okay the biden
harris campaign has chosen its side
and they've decided that they are going
to side with the criminals rather than
the cops
and this could not be made more obvious
than in the case of jacob blake
now the new york times is mirroring this
as well we'll get to the new york times
building up jacob blake is a hero i am
not kidding you this is a real thing
they're building up an alleged rapist
the victim completely disappears by the
way
completely doesn't matter the the female
victim remember the me too
remember say her name when it came to
girl when it came to women being
sexually assaulted remember all that
me too moment yeah that doesn't matter
anymore we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now is not a great time to go to the
post office but you still have to send
lots of mail hopefully your business is
still doing a lot of business
and that means you need to get those
packages out the door well how can you
accomplish this
saving time and saving money well you
use stamps.com with stamps.com you can
print postage on demand you can avoid it
going to the post office
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com offers ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges here at daily
wire we were early adapters here we've
been using stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time stamps.com will
bring all the mailing and shipping
services you need right to your computer
in the comfort of your home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices
or an online seller shipping out
products or just working from home and
you need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just leave it for the mail
carrier schedule a pickup
drop in the mailbox it is indeed that
simple again you get those big discounts
five cents off every stamp up to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer and we've
been doing it here at the office for
years just go to stamps.com right now
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro and you get
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitment go to stamps.com
enter code shapiro at the top of the
homepage and get that special incredible
deal four week trial plus free postage
and digital scale no long term
commitment that is stamps.com click on
the mic
at the top of the homepage type in
shapiro okay so the new york times
is also attempting to push the
lie that jacob blake is a wonderful hero
you know it's funny candace owens got a
lot of flack for suggesting that people
were lionizing
george floyd right and and this led dave
chappelle to attack candace owens and
suggest that she was a bad person
because she was pointing out that it's
not merely that people were upset about
what happened to george floyd
they're also lionizing him as some sort
of american hero being buried in a gold
casket and all the rest
the media are giving the full treatment
to jacob blake i mean they are giving me
full sycophantic treatment to an alleged
rapist
with multiple children by multiple
mothers i mean this guy is this is not a
model
of excellent human behavior in fact if
you don't want to be shot by the police
i have a couple of recommendations one
don't rape anybody two don't resist
arrest when they come to arrest you for
raping somebody
these are just a couple of of tips of
handy tips don't reach into your car for
a
knife on the floorboards a few handy
tips but apparently none of that matters
because you'll be lionized as a hero
by the media so long as you are black
and the police officer is white and so
long as it serves a political purpose
for a democrat
and that is what is happening right now
here's an article from the new york
times today
jacob blake rare survivor at center of
police protests
starts telling his own story isn't this
going to be empowering it's so
empowering guys
in a video recorded from his hospital
bed mr blake was shot by the police says
it hurts to breathe
it hurts to sleep demonstrations against
police violence have been filled with
the chance of victims names
george floyd brianna taylor tamir rice
eric garner in recent days a new name
jacob blake
has been called out in protests across
the country in that list though mr blake
a black man who was repeatedly shot in
the back by a white police officer in
kenosha wisconsin
is also set apart okay you might notice
that um that description of the crime
lacks a little bit of context according
to the new york times he was just a
black guy repeatedly shot in the back by
a white police officer
none of the he was reaching for a knife
in his car none of the he repeatedly
disobeyed
orders by the cops none of the he
violently resisted arrest which he did
none of that he was called the cops were
called to the scene because he was
violating a restraining order for a
woman who alleged rape
none of that makes it to the new york
times piece weird weird guys
according to the new york times unlike
so many of the people who have become
grim symbols for a movement mr blake
survived and has begun
to tell his story okay
buried in paragraph 17 of this fees
buried in paragraph 17 of this piece is
the little known fact
that blake has pled not guilty to three
domestic charges against him including a
sexual assault count
the charges were filed in july on the
day mr blake was shot the woman who
reported the assault called 911 in 9-1-1
saying that mr blake was at her home the
kenosha police said they were trying to
arrest mr blake when the shooting
occurred
okay then you just say they were trying
to there's a tape of it guys i mean like
this is all on tape the trial in that
case has been scheduled for november
although
it could be delayed ben crump the civil
rights attorney said blake was still
coming to terms with the public
attention to what had happened to him
and what it might mean
for the months in the months ahead krump
said he hasn't been able to fully grasp
what a symbol
he has become adding that blake was
mostly focused on making sure that his
young children
three of whom witnessed the shooting are
not traumatized and they understand that
he will emerge from this
krum said the way he's trying to be a
strong black father for his children is
the way he's taking on the mission of
this movement you know it's a great way
to be a strong black father
not allegedly raping people and then
resisting arrest when they come to
arrest you
that would be a great way to be a better
father period no matter your race
but the new york times runs this long
piece nowhere in this piece you actually
find out what he did
or what he was alleged to have done but
don't worry jacob blake is now a hero
so here is this video that rocketed
around the internet of jacob blake
complaining about his injuries
and pick better heroes people pick
better heroes
i got stables in my back staples in my
damn stomach
you do not want to have to deal with
this man
24 hours every 24 hours is pain this
number pain
it hurts to breathe it hurts to sleep it
hurts to move from side to side it hurts
to eat
please i'm telling you change our lives
out there we can stick together
make some money make make everything
easier for our people out here man
because there's so much time that has
been wasted
make some money again this man allegedly
raped a woman
that is why the police were there okay
so
when you set the narrative that america
is evil and systemically racist and
horrible across the board
the predictable result is that no matter
what the circumstances of any individual
police interaction with a black person
it will be treated by the media and by a
population that has been taught by the
media that america is a horrible place
as an incident of white on black
brutality and that is what we've seen
across the country and by the way
it will be latched onto by agitators of
all races particularly
upper-class white people a shocking
number of antifa members and rioters and
looters have actually been upper-class
white people we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that you're engaging with media an
awful lot these days i mean it's an
election season and there's a lot going
on in the world that means that you need
an excellent pair
of premium wireless earbuds especially
if you can get them at less than half
the price
of the other guys which is why i
recommend wireless earbuds from raycon
raycon's newest model the everyday e25s
those are the best ones yet six hours of
play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
more compact design and noise isolating
fit
which is excellent if your kids are
screaming you while you're on the phone
this is a frequent occurrence in my home
raycon earbuds they are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires no stems and
you can give them a try right now
because they have a 45 day free return
policy
so you can make sure they are the pair
of wireless earbuds for you
they look great they also fit your ear
perfectly unlike the other one size fits
all options you can actually customize
them so they fit your ear really really
comfortably and don't fall out for a
limited time
get 15 off your order at buy raycon.com
that is b-u-i-r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash
ben
for a special 15 discount on raycon
wireless earbuds make sure to check it
out now while the deal is still running
raycon dot com slash ben once more that
is b-y-r-a-y-c-one dot com slash ben you
get 15
off your order and it's not gonna cost
you an arm and a leg like the other guys
and if it's better and it looks better
go check them out right now buy raycon
dot com slash ben all righty so
over the weekend a lot of different
incidents of violence happening in a
range of different cities
so in rochester there is a particularly
uh
weird incident in which uh people
attacked an outdoor restaurant
and you can see uh the race of the
people who are attacking me out to a
restaurant it's not
it's largely white people because this
is dispossessed white people who are
looking for a reason to be angry about
their lives
uh and so here's some tape from
rochester where a restaurant was
basically overrun
karen black lives matter flags and uh
these tables are systemically racist
guys
i'm gonna knock over some chairs gotta
knock over some glasses wreck the
outdoor restaurant in rochester
in the name of systemic injustice yeah
toss some chairs you know really go for
it
that heat lamp right there seems
systemically racist knock that sucker
right over
really good stuff a lot of uh a lot of
pissed off white people looking to wreck
a restaurant
this is all this is good for america
and i feel like the the biden harris
campaign is going to reign it in
by praising people who commit active
disgusting crime uh and then are shot in
the process of resisting police
that that seems like that'll probably
heal things in dc protesters were
blocking reporters so that's always it
that's always good news we've been told
by the way the same reporters who try
and cover afford the protesters and
pretend they're nice people again a
bunch of
white people who have decided to glom
onto the movement and do the hard work
according to robin d'angelo according to
frederick kunkel of the washington post
quote protesters are now blocking media
from filming their demonstration
shining lights into a reporter's face
blocking shots with fans umbrellas
and following like quote unquote minders
so good times over in washington dc
over in portland we had an instance in
which people were throwing molotov
cocktails at the cops and one of the
protesters who was standing in front of
the cops
was hit by the molotov cocktail leading
to him being set on fire and then
ironically having to be put out by the
very police officers he was protesting
so the cops were
systemically evil had to put out this
man who uh
who was on fire he's standing middle
street protesting the police
and um yeah that's some that's some
video right there
they're trying to put him out i mean
that's
you know if you got protesting the
police and you get on you get sent on
fire by a molotov cocktail thrown by one
of the members of your own side
and then the police have to come and
save you because your idiot friends are
trying to put out a fire with a trash
can
as opposed to you know an actual fire
extinguisher where the cops show up and
try to help you
yeah well done everybody that really
really solid stuff meanwhile molotov
cocktails were found by the seattle pd
so the seattle they they had an instance
of somebody throwing mouth cocktails at
the cops last night seattle pd released
an image
of people carrying around molotov
cocktails
uh probably the most evocative imagery
was not even a man being set on fire by
a molotov cocktail thrown by presumed
antifa members
it was these pittsburgh protests in
pittsburgh there were protests
where people went to an outdoor
restaurant and again decided that this
is a good look it's always a good look
when you're trying to
just harass random people who are out
dining for the evening
they went to a they went to some sort of
outdoor restaurant
and some lady decides that she is
entitled to somebody else's beer
so she literally just walks up to the
table where people are just eating
outdoors
and then grabs the beer there's a black
woman
walking up to this elderly white couple
just walks up and starts drinking the
lady's beer
she's wearing a shirt that says nazi
lives don't matter which is the irony
of um modern-day fascists walking up to
other people and just taking their stuff
and seizing it in the name of racial
justice
pretty incredible stuff right there the
great irony of course is that the
elderly couple has covered so
sad for that lady sad for that lady so
all of this
is making the country a better place and
this is why when you hear biden harris
they're going to calm the tensions
they're going to calm the tensions the
only way that democrats call them these
kind of tensions is by suggesting to the
protesters to
protesters that they are going to do
what they want they're going to calm the
tensions
in the same way that anybody who caves
to arsonists and terrorists calms
tensions
they cave to them if you appease them
then presumably they will get a little
bit calmer
the only problem is that you are now
making it so that the math works
that every time they decide to get
violent you're going to do more work on
their behalf
i don't think that the american people
are particularly into being blackmailed
especially not by
the wonderful people who are doing who
are engaged in this sort of blackmail
in the first place there's an amazing
story
of a of a wealthy college student who
was arrested
over the weekend for engaging in rioting
this is in new york city
her name is clara craber she was among
those arrested after a vandalism spree
on friday in the flat iron district
where demonstrators
were protesting in favor of blm they did
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
damage to businesses in manhattan
so apparently she has now been charged
she was arrested
who is she well she was arrested at her
family's second home
she's an undergrad at rice university
her father is a psychiatrist who teaches
at columbia university department of
psychiatry
so we are now living out philip roth's
american pastoral her mother is an
architect at a prestigious manhattan
firm
the family in 2016 purchased a 1.8
million apartment on the upper east side
they also own a home with four
fireplaces in connecticut
one law enforcement source told the post
i wonder how her rich parents feel about
their daughter
how would they feel if they graffitied
their townhouse this girl should be the
poster child for white privilege
growing up on the upper east side and
another home in connecticut this is the
height of hypocrisy
but of course it isn't the height of
hypocrisy if you engage in a movement
that says that america is systemically
racist and that that is basically the
fault of white people and the only way
that white people can alleviate
their historic systemic racism is by
leading the way in creating change and
the way that change is created is by
overthrowing all systems
so of course she's rebelling against
exactly the systems that made her
parents wealthy
because those systems are racist she is
doing something virtuous see
she's even leaving behind her own wealth
she's arrested her at her family's
second home
by the way so all very very good stuff
and it ties into something
much deeper ideologically speaking we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that because
you're engaged with a lot of media these
days because you're online a lot maybe
you're working from home
that means that you're getting a lot of
blue light coming in to those retinas
and that means they're probably having a
tough time sleeping it's possible you're
getting headaches
staring at screens all day is actually
quite bad in terms of headaches and in
terms of eye strain
and this is why you need some excellent
blue
blue light glasses and i'm talking here
about felix grays
felix gray will filter out 90 of blue
light in the most damaging range
eliminates 99
of glare through a proprietary
industry-leading lens technology only
available
with felix gray this lens technology is
super durable it is much stronger than
some of the other lens technology you'll
get where people just kind of paint
something on a glass that's not the way
it works felix gray frames our hand
finished from durable
super lightweight italian acetate you
can order online and the glasses will
ship directly to you
with hard case and lens cloth included
you can try them for 30 days risk-free
if your stream if your screens are not
easier on the eyes you send them back
for a full refund you really have
nothing to lose except for the headaches
and the eye strain go to felix
greyglasses.com for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses on
the market that is f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y
felix grey glasses dot com slash ben
shipping and returns are totally free at
felix gray felixgrayglasses.com go check
them out right now
i love my felix grays they definitely
have ensured that the amount of screen
time i get doesn't take a toll on my
eyes or my sleep
felix grayglasses.com go check them out
right now alrighty in just a second
we're going to
get to how all of this ties into deeper
ideological commitments that have been
made
by the left and exactly how those
ideological commitments
can be fought we'll get to that in just
one second first as part of our daily
wire audience there are a number of ways
you can take in the podcast
you can listen on apple podcast spotify
another podcast app you can also watch
our podcast on youtube facebook or over
at dailywire.com here's the bottom line
we are making our content available to
you anywhere you watch or listen
and now we're introducing a new upgraded
experience daily wire is now on apple tv
and roku
so members can enjoy all the visual
elements of this podcast on your big
screen either live or on demand
find the daily wear on apple tv or roku
go download today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout get
off your membership purchase the deal
will not last long fast if you want live
shows on your big screen
plus the one-of-a-kind highly coveted
often imitated never duplicated
leftist here is tumblr again that is
dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with code watch
and download the daily wire on your
apple tv
and roku today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
so democrats are having an exorbitantly
hard time condemning antifa and
certainly black lives matter you won't
see anybody on the democratic side
condemn black lives matter and the
associated violence
involved with black lives matter that
will never happen at all over the
weekend joe biden was asked specifically
about nt funding said yes i can demand i
condemn that violence and all other
violence which of course is both sizing
it in the same way
that donald trump was criticized for in
charlottesville i remember because i was
one of the people who criticized him for
it
okay well bret baer as simone sanders
who is a spokesperson
for the biden campaign why biden had not
specifically condemned
antifa like do a full speech do a sister
soldier moment talk about the evils of
antifa and the excesses of blm
but biden of course will not do that
because he is deathly afraid of losing
the left wing of his base
in a competitive election so here's bret
baer asking a simple question to simone
sanders she does not give a simple
answer
this week the former vice president has
condemned that rioting and looting and
violence spoke out about it
but he has yet to con condemn antifa a
group that
is behind a lot of the violence
specifically
why brett the vice president has been
very clear he condemns
all forms of violence and frankly what
you heard him say in the speech that he
gave
on monday of last week was it doesn't
matter what political party
you belong to it doesn't matter what
your political beliefs are
violence is wrong okay that does not cut
it i'm sorry violence is wrong
does not cut it when you refuse to
specifically talk about the evils of
antifa or specifically refuse to talk
about the evils of blm the organization
as well as the protests that have led to
violence across the country
hey bret baer then asked a more specific
question to simone sanders he says you
know 13 members of the biden campaign
tried to bail out rioters in minneapolis
you got anything on that simone and the
answer of course is no
to the dozen plus biden campaign
staffers who donated to this minnesota
freedom fund
have any regrets about that now that at
least one person bailed out
has been rearrested on a serious charge
right it
was not and has not been our campaign
position of bailing anyone out
so i'm unsure about specifically what
you're speaking well kamala harris
tweeted about it she said if you're able
to chip into the
minnesota freedom fund to help post bail
for those protesting on the ground in
minnesota
please do whoops whoops and then she was
like well you know
we don't like violence in any form okay
no honestly honestly the the biden
campaign seems
kind of sanguine about violence so long
as it comes from the left
it is violence of the alt-right and
white supremacists that they are very
very concerned about now
you can be concerned about all of those
forms of violence but it's the violence
on your side of the aisle you have to
speak up against
particularly okay this is one of the
things i've been saying for a very long
time you can go back and listen to old
episodes of this show
how many times have i done full episodes
on the evils of the alt-right and white
supremacy
literally dozens of times on the show
dozens of times okay anything that is
perceived to be violent
needs to be condemned very specifically
and its motivations analyzed but here's
the problem for democrats they don't
very often want to analyze the
motivations
of blm or antifa because they might come
up against the harsh reality which is
that blm and antifa
imitate many of their talking points and
they agree with them on many of these
ideas
how do you know this because they'll say
it out loud ilhan omar the radical
democratic congresswoman from
minneapolis endorsed by nancy pelosi
so not radical mainstream democrat okay
let's just stop calling her a radical
she's not a radical she's a mainstream
democrat ilhan omar is a mainstream
democrat who poses on the cover of
rolling stone with nancy pelosi
okay she's she's an awful anti-semite
she uh she famously characterized 9 11
as something
happening to some people basically hey
ilhan omar is is a is an awful human
being
ilhan omar is a mainstream democrat
she's been embraced by the democratic
party and here was ilhan omar suggesting
that what we were watching in our
streets
is an uprising over centuries of racism
and oppression that is what we are
watching in our streets
so it's very difficult for them from for
the democratic party to look deeply at
antifa or blm
when they are reading from the same
hymnal here is ilhan omar reading from
that hymnal
we are in the midst of an ongoing
uprising
over centuries of racial neglect and
oppression
we can't talk about the protesters in
minneapolis or kenosha
or sports teams nationwide without first
looking inward
we maintain a system that grinds
millions
into desperate poverty a system that
doesn't provide the most
basic necessities like food shelter and
medicine
ah it's an uprising and again there is
something deeply ironic about a woman
coming to the united states from an
impoverished position right i mean she
came from somalia
to the united states gaining a seat in
congress and talking about the grinding
evil of the united states and it's
racial
and ethnic oppression i mean it's just
frankly it's a pretty disgusting thing
to do it is a disgusting thing to do
there are many criticisms you can make
of the american system
the idea that the american system grinds
millions of people
into poverty and is complicit in racism
and oppression and brutality that coming
from a sitting i mean she in her very
own person is a rebuke to her own
perspective but
this is a mainstream democratic
perspective let us stop pretending this
is not a mainstream democratic
perspective when joe biden
goes out there and he says nice things
about the declaration or the
constitution or when obama does it
that is just surface level nonsense for
people who are gullible
because the heart and soul of the
democratic party is in fact without if
it were not nancy pelosi had every
opportunity to endorse
ilhan omar's opponents in a primary she
did not instead they've decided to
integrate this
into the heart of the democratic party
and
this is an ideological thing it is it is
the reason why
because again this should not be tough
like from a political perspective joe
biden doesn't actually need the support
of antifa
from a political perspective joe biden
doesn't even need to go along
with the violence of blm he could say
listen i think they're they're
you know that our police are not
systemically racist
that there are corrections that we can
make but we live in a country where
we're all trying to do our best he
doesn't actually need to go full radical
on this he does not
the reason that he does is because he
thinks he needs to do that
either politically or because he truly
believes it one of the two
he has decided to embrace the ohana omar
position
kamala harris is much clearer about i
mean she fully embraces the ohio omar
position
whenever you hear people by the way
categorizing as quote unquote uprisings
the the violence that is being done in
the street maxine waters did it in 1992
circa the la riots
she also she called it the la uprising
the same thing is happening here
this is why the democrats are having a
tough time condemning this because they
only disagree about the means they don't
disagree about the ends nor do they
disagree about the arguments
and these arguments have very very deep
roots one of the arguments is an
argument made by critical race theory so
critical race theory is the basic idea
that all human interactions are
basically power struggles
and all human interactions in the united
states particularly can be analyzed
through the lens of race so every policy
that is created in the united states
is actually just a reflection of
underlying racial power dynamics
critical race theory is an offshoot of
critical legal studies critical legal
studies
is the theory that there is no actual
principled interpretation of law
instead others are people pretending
that they are doing principled
interpretation of law when in fact
they're simply attempting to effectuate
systems of power on their own behalf
critical legal studies came about in the
1960s 1970s
thinkers like roberto unger were big
proponents of critical legal studies
it's
an entire way of teaching law i mean
they taught this at harvard law school
there's an entire way of teaching law
that is deeply engaged with the idea
that law is itself an exercise
in oppression and power and so the only
question is who has the power and who
gets to wield it
now critical legal studies basically
destroys small r republicanism
it destroys legal systems because if
legal systems are not predicated on
principle they are merely a competition
among power dynamics
well then why not side with your tribe
and try and grab power
critical race theory is just an adjunct
to that
as the first proponent of the early
proponents was derek bell derek bell was
a big proponent of critical race theory
and his basic view of american law
and american politics is the same as
ibrahim kennedy's which is that all of
american law
is white supremacy derek bell is very
clear about this in his own writings
he was also promoted at the time by a
young harvard law student named barack
obama who famously hugged derrick bell
when derek bell was denied tenure at
harvard law school
there were big rallies about derrick
bell and what should derek bell be
maintained there
this was not legal scholarship right it
was just politics masquerading as
legal scholarship but critical race
theory has become
sort of the the go-to anti-racism
program so it used to be sort of a
fringy thing that you saw in upper level
law schools it is now bled down into the
mainstream
it is what you see when you see people
like robin deangelo or ibrahim kendi
being hired by
you by universities and by corporations
and by members of the federal government
to teach about anti-racism again
the basic going theory is that the
declaration of independence is a lie
it's a bunch of highfalutin ideas that
mean nothing
the constitution is merely an attempt by
white people to maintain their own power
that all systems
of power all systems of law are in fact
merely a cloak
for disguised racial oppression right
that is the the basis of critical race
theory it's also the basis of the 1619
project which springs
from the same place and ilhan omar kind
of bumper stickers it when she says that
what we're watching now is an uprising
against racism
and against oppression and that all
systems of america are rife with racism
and oppression
the 6019 project is basically an
offshoot of critical race theory that
all of american history is just a racial
struggle
and it's white supremacy in action so
the trump administration is rightly
fighting back against this president
trump said over the weekend that the
department of education
would be investigating whether
california schools are using the new
york times 1619 project
in public school curricula the the 6019
project is of course
anti-factual it is garbage i've analyzed
it at length on this show there's a big
analysis of it in my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps it basically
blames everything from traffic patterns
to housing to maternal mortality rates
and disparity between maternal mortality
rates on american america's history of
slavery and jim crow
trump tweeted out department of
education is looking at this if so they
will not be funded
now i just want to know all the people
who are very upset with uh president
trump for suggesting that he is going to
cut via the department of education
funding to california based on
their teaching of the anti-factual 1619
project which again is anti-american
propaganda that suggests that america
was not founded in 1776 the
declaration's principles mean nothing
it was founded instead on slavery and
racial oppression they're very angry at
trump because they're saying well why
can't california run its own ship okay i
have an idea let's just eliminate the
department of education all together
it's been a long time republican
proposal if california wants to
propagandize to its children
all right let's get rid of the doa
entirely no more common core
no more federal standards get rid of the
department of education on the federal
level
as a whole frankly that'd be something
i'd be very much in favor of i don't
think the federal government has any
business in how i teach my children
but so long as the federal government is
going to be involved then it seems to me
in the federal government's interest not
to having states not to have
states teach propaganda about how evil
america is
russell vaught the director of the
office of management and budget has also
instructed heads of federal agencies
to dramatically alter quote racial
sensitivity training programs
for employees deeming them un-american
propaganda in a two-page memo and by the
way the memo is correct this is
anti-american propaganda
russell vaught put out a statement says
it has come to the president's attention
that executive branch agencies have
spent millions of taxpayer dollars to
date
training quote-unquote training
government workers to believe divisive
anti-american propaganda
for example according to press reports
employees across the executive branch
have been required to attend trainings
where they are told that virtually all
white people contribute to racism
or where they are required to say that
they quote unquote benefit from racism
according to press reports in some cases
these trainings
have further claimed that there is
racism embedded in the belief that
america is the land of opportunity
or the belief that the most qualified
person should receive a job these types
of trainings not only run counter to the
fundamental beliefs for which our nation
has stood since its inception but they
also engendered division and resentment
within the federal workforce
we cannot accept our employees receiving
training that seeks to undercut our core
values as americans and drives division
within our workforce
so the all agencies have been directed
to begin to identify all contracts or
other agencies spending related to any
training on critical race theory white
privilege or any other training or
propaganda effort that teaches or
suggests either one that the united
states is an inherently racist or evil
country or two that any race or
ethnicity is inherently racist or evil
in addition all agencies should begin to
identify all available avenues within
the law to cancel any such contracts and
or to divert federal dollars away
from these un-american propaganda
training sessions of course this has led
the left to say that
trump is instead trying to defend racism
no no
no no no that is not what this is if you
defund the 1619 project again
an anti-historical bag of garbage or for
you to fund
these diversity training initiatives led
by grifters like robin deangelo i mean
she's a full-on grifter what a living
that lady has made for herself
upper-class white lady lecturing
everybody else on racism and all you
have to do to alleviate your own racism
to cleanse yourself of the racist
thetans is to hire robin d'angelo twenty
thousand bucks a pop or ibram kennedy at
twenty thousand bucks a pop
and magically magically your racism is
now relieved good for the trump
administration
on this stuff this is an ideological
battle it really is
and the fact is the democratic party has
decided
full scale to embrace this agenda they
have and joe biden is merely a front man
for this
because joe biden appears not to be
radical joe biden appears not to agree
with some of this stuff
but i would love to see him forcefully
announce it which he never will he'll
never forcefully announce the 16-19
project he'll praise it
he'll never forcefully denounce the idea
that america is a land of racism
intolerance and oppression
he agrees with it or at least he's weak
need enough to cave to those people
who do agree with it so you know again
one of the things that you have to gauge
in this election like every election is
whether it is a competition between
individual figures
which is very often how people see
elections it's trump versus biden or
whether it is a conflict between
movements and ideas and trump
may be a highly imperfect a highly
imperfect vessel for the expression
of american ideals and when i say highly
imperfect that is putting it
extraordinarily mildly i think the man
has tremendous tremendous and terrible
character flaws
that i've criticized at length on this
program but if i'm forced to choose
between a party
that is fully engaged in a 1619
mentality that says america is
systemically racist
a party that fully embraces the alleged
evils of jacob blake and rips the cops
versus a party that says no you know
what america is not systemically racist
it's police are not systemically racist
we have to identify instances of racism
and fight them if that is my choice that
is no choice at all that is an
extraordinarily easy choice
all the democrats had to do was be not
nuts and they have been unfortunately
unable to do it like at all at all
now meanwhile there's been a tremendous
amount of
of media synchrony again for joe biden
the easy thing that the media have been
trying to mimic the joe biden versus
donald trump
race narrative and i don't mean like
race is i mean like
the the uh the 2020 race they've been
trying to mimic biden's narrative but
biden's narrative is a conflict between
people it's not a conflict between ideas
and so in order to promulgate that they
have to make it into nice old joe
nice old joe and the media are into this
full scale
so over the weekend over the last
several days joe biden has just gotten
the richest media treatment
i've ever seen so biden literally cannot
handle himself on the trail
that is not a conspiracy theory that is
a reality now how do you know that uh so
i got critiqued over the weekend
uh for suggesting that joe biden is not
with it
people are saying well you know if you
really want to help republicans then
what you would really do
is you would talk about how he's with it
and then he would he would undercut
expectations okay but that's not my job
i'm gonna tell you the truth
joe biden is not with it it's very
obvious to anybody who watches him for
more than seven minutes that he is not
even what joe biden used to be
and what joe biden used to be wasn't
that great in the first place well let's
be honest about that joe biden was a
weird
dude who's who had logaria he was
constantly just
jabbering nonsensically about random
stuff there's a reason
that when he ran first in 1842
there's a reason why joe biden has run
for president one million times and lost
every time
okay so over the weekend joe biden was
doing a zoom session
again this is what he does now he's in
his basement and does zoom sessions and
he
literally was being fed answers in his
teleprompter and he couldn't read the
teleprompter led to this awkward
exchange
what will your administration do to help
them give them that chance
thank you move it up here
you know there used to be a basic
bargain in this country
workers shared in the wealth their work
helped create
move it up here is him talking to his
teleprompter operator
because presumably he needs to be fed
the answers the good news is the media
will cover for him no matter what joe
biden it doesn't matter that his
campaign is
basically a mess he will be covered for
no matter what and it is a mess by the
way we'll get to his coveted comments in
just one second first i got to show you
how the media have just been sick of
fans sycophantically carrying around his
drool club i mean he's literally
drooling and they are carrying around a
bucket
for him to drool in well and sh well
well telling you that not only are they
not water carriers for him he is totally
with it
yeah i mean it's amazing it's amazing so
gloria borger over on cnn
she literally called empathy his
superpower okay let me just
put this out there joe biden doesn't
have any superpowers he has no
superpowers at this point
trobiden's only superpower is that he
cannot escape the basement
okay it's like an episode it's like an
installment of saw except he's not
actually changing the wall and there's
no threat to him and he still can't
leave the basement
here's gloria borger saying empathy is
joe biden's superpower
looking at the grief there and also
empathy biden has talked about empathy
as sort of his number one you know
way to really connect with the average
american
yeah he he does and i i talked with
somebody who's worked with him who said
it's his superpower
he reaches out to people in kind of a
pastoral way
because he said to me look i can
understand their grief
and um and i think it helps him in a way
to share
his own wow wow so that's the superpower
is that he's nice guys
because again the media are trying to
boil this race down into trump versus
biden as opposed to the movements they
represent
and then they mischaracterize the
movements they represent of course blm
is all about peaceful change
well well apparently the trump
supporters are all about violent evil
we'll get to that in a moment also
because seriously there's an entire
article in the daily beast
today talking about how leftists are
bracing for pro-trump violence after the
election
show me the massive episodes of
pro-trump violence
where where is all where are all these
evil right-wingers burning cities
like where are they i'm not talking
about you know the clashes between the
proud boys we're a small group
and you know a fringy group who have not
been embraced by the republican
establishment
and antifa members and i'm not talking
about you know white supremacists who
have been actively
thrust out of anything resembling the
right wing by people in power
i'm if we're talking about widespread
violence i think we all know where the
widespread violence is gonna come from
after the election it's gonna if trump
wins there will be widespread burning of
cities and we all know that that's the
case the daily beast however is trying
to make it
that it's about how the how the right
wing is the true violent
wing of the of the american political
spectrum in any case
the media really pushing
joe biden hard i mean hard so on friday
joe biden did a little presser
that little presser involved the media
massaging his back for an hour
here's a montage of the questions that
joe biden was asked these are not
questions
okay this is them feeding him answers
about how wonderful he is this is like a
barbara walters interview if you were a
tweet what kind of tweet would you be
joe biden here we go last night
president trump mocked you for wearing a
mask
and said that this is a sign that you
must have some quote big
issues he says this even though he knows
that
according to scientists and public
health officials wearing masks saves
lives
he asked you about another thing the
president said last night he
once again suggested to his supporters
that they should consider voting twice
if they're in one of those states that
can allow you to request an absentee
ballot
say fill that out and then go try voting
again in person
state officials have said it's a felony
when you hear these remarks
suckers losers recoiling from amputees
what does it tell you about president
trump's soul
you said today is the angriest you've
you've been
as a presidential candidate
um but you said you're trying to
restrain yourself
are there a lot of people out there who
are supporting you or inclined to not
vote for the president who would say why
isn't joe biden angrier
oh my god so the questions are why
aren't you angrier
what's wrong with donald trump's soul
and also
why are you the greatest person who has
ever lived job really tough stuff there
from the media
uh why don't people trust the media guys
why why is the media losing circulation
to folks like us over at the daily wire
why
why don't why are people tuning over to
this show as opposed to watching cnn i
can't imagine i literally can't imagine
donald trump correctly pointed out that
joe biden is getting questions from
children this is exactly right here is
president trump going after the media
i watched the interview with sleepy joe
biden
and he didn't ask questions you didn't
ask questions like that
read the questions yes they were like
meant for a child
those questions were meant for a child
smiles on faces of reporters
not like you and you they were smiles on
the request what do you think take a
look at those questions that they asked
him
they were not meant for a grown-up they
were meant for a child
this is exactly right by the way why is
it that the media don't ask tough
questions like bret baer asked simone
sanders about why exactly
joe biden won't dissociate from people
in his own campaign
who are trying to spend money to bail
out protesters including kamala harris
why
okay why is it that the the the biden
harris campaign over the weekend
you know they've been saying we need to
follow the science follow the science
fight covet follow the science follow
the signs and then over and over over
the weekend
kamala harris suggested that donald
trump was going to rush out of vaccine
that he would somehow cudgel the medical
community into approving the vaccine
and therefore she wouldn't take the
vaccine okay this is
this is bordering on anti-vaxxer stuff
it really is but this is the party of
science
this is the party of of wonder here is
simone sanders she wouldn't answer if
joe biden would take the vaccine
will joe biden get the vaccine if it's
available
well look brad again as i just noted
first and foremost i think folks have
asked um
we've had lots of conversations about
testing right and as folks know now
vice president biden and senator harris
are are being regularly tested as our
campaign staff
but first and foremost at the top of the
my top of mind for vice president biden
is are the american people getting what
they need what they need you know the
white house has
has testing uh brett you know folks are
tested very regularly coming in and out
of the white house anyone who's around
the president
but that testing that level of testing
is not available to folks across this
country
so um that is that is not an answer and
then kamala harris said that you would
literally not trust any vaccine promoted
by trump
she wouldn't trust a vaccine promoted by
trump now again let's be straight about
this
nobody's asking you to trust donald
trump on the vaccine they're asking you
to trust the medical community on the
vaccine are you really of the opinion
that donald trump can simply cudgel
anthony fauci and deborah burks into
endorsing a vaccine that is inherently
unsafe
here is here is harris implying that on
cnn let's just say there's a vaccine
that is approved and even distributed
before the election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us
i will say that i would not
trust donald trump and it would have to
be
a credible source of information that
talks about the
the efficacy and the and the reliability
of whatever he's talking about i will
not take his word for it he wants us to
inject bleach no i will not take it so
first of all it's a lie he doesn't want
anybody to inject bleach but second of
all
she literally also said in this
interview that she believes that donald
trump is muzzling his scientists so even
if the scientists endorse the vaccine so
this is the anti-vaxxer kind of stuff
trump correctly said that biden and her
should apologize for the anti-vaccine
rhetoric he's not wrong about this
biden and he's very liberal running mate
the most liberal person in congress by
the way
is not a competent person in my opinion
would destroy this
country and would destroy this economy
should immediately apologize for the
reckless anti-vaccine rhetoric that they
are talking right now talking about
endangering lives and
it undermines science okay by the way
not wrong about this here is a poll from
cbs
news this is a battleground tracker poll
of national registered voters if a
coronavirus vaccine became available
would you
get one as soon as possible 21 in july
that was 32 percent
consider it wait to see what happens 58
never get one
21 okay so literally only one in five
american voters say
that they would get one as soon as
possible that is down from one in three
american voters and that is because
democrats keep saying that donald trump
is gonna rush out of vaccine in order to
kill you
also i'm amazed to see that nobody seems
to be asking tough questions to biden
and harris about what exactly they would
do on covet
remember part of their campaign strategy
was trump botched covet so here was
kamala harris who said over the weekend
that wearing a mask would be the
standard in the united states if they
were elected
to high office
it's about a national standard everyone
should wear a mask and here's the thing
about this
none of us likes wearing a mask nobody
likes it right
there's a difference between a standard
sacrifice right there's a difference
between a standard
and a mandate would it be a federal
mandate
under the biden harris administration it
would be a standard
everything's hilarious in the world of
i've always told my children
if you ever want to identify the villain
in a movie it's the person who's always
laughing villains are always having a
great time in the movies right
palpatine's always laughing it's just
it's fun to be a villain
so you can identify who exactly is the
villain in this scenario
i'm amazed that kamala harris and biden
have been able to get away with this
they keep saying that masking would be
the standard the standard joe biden
openly acknowledged over the weekend it
would be unconstitutional for the
federal government to issue a national
mass mandate
so here is joe biden and finally
answering so in other words
his policy is exactly the same as
trump's here's here's joe biden
sounds like you might want a stronger
federal you know response
to this and do you trust the governors
to handle what's best for their states
well i hope we could trust the governors
but here's the deal
the federal government there's a
constitutionalist whether the federal
government could issue such a mandate
i don't think constitutionally they
could so i wouldn't issue a mandate
but i plead with i carry my mask with me
everywhere i go
i'd set an example wow well that would
make a huge difference
joe biden by the way you know how little
people trust their authorities on covet
now and this is all earned here are the
polls
on how much people trust various sources
about coveted you ready you're governor
in march 69 of americans trusted their
governor on covet now it is 55
the cdc 86 of people in march trusted
the cdc on covet
now it is 54 donald trump in march 46
percent of americans trusted him on
covet
now it is 40 the national media 45
trusted them in march now it is 35 5
below trump and 20
below their governor all of that is
earned all of that
is earned media asking tough questions
of the biden harris campaign
as always alrighty well later today
we'll be back here with two additional
hours of content including
president trump saying he could spend up
to 100 million of his own dollars on his
campaign we'll analyze that particular
claim and we'll get to trump fighting
back against the military and military
members uh well top ranking military
members we'll get to a lot more
you'll have to go check out
dailywire.com so we will see you here
later i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavette
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew clavin
show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton